citizens of the reject Nation it is time
once again back from Rome to get into
the DC Animated Universe or the DC
Universe that's animated people have
corrected a lot about which thing it is
I don't even know DC animated movie
Universe
rolls right off the tongue it's what
we're watching now we are watching
Constantine today but which Constantine
is a jump oh it's it's I'm prepared it's
city of demons the city of demons have
you seen it I have not that is the
tradition of this show not only do we
call it a different acronym every time
but we figured out in real time what we
haven't watched very excited about it
please do hit that like hit that
subscribe hit that comment like type
when you're hitting but let us know what
you want to see next in that very
comment bar as you may have noticed
we're going willy-nilly to and fro in
and out of the house of mystery as we
dive into these movies what's going to
be next only Greg knows frankly we don't
but if you'd like to be a patron and
find out what it's like to watch all of
it start defend with every bit of our
resting faces
kept intact join the patreon without
further Ado let's get into Constantine
oh I already like it oh it's really dark
we got a little top left corner action
that's right this is for men yeah
yeah and women and a yes
oh [__] I mean she's not driving
but the word car is in the opening
Raven's car don't you forget it that's
when Birds Drive how are you doing mate
treating you good are they spoke to Dr
Hunter he thinks you're making some
progress
before you know it we'll be back in the
road with a band yeah Billy Idol
not the esoteric stuff you usually go
for
cool
[Music]
Johnny
are we seeing into his origins or his
present day Johnny what are you doing
you swore you were gonna stop no more
magic right
oh not all has a cast that was some
beautiful magic I can't let it happen
again
whoa
hey it's easy on him Jesus yeah
[Laughter]
all right mood's set I like how
harrowing they all are yeah ah finally
the freeway I was worried no one would
drive hey
Hollywood
Queen of Angels
[Applause]
last time I ever drink like that
they're famous last words
breakfast
cool
people dead too
you're still dreaming
oh yeah
I like that little coats yeah
but they're so good at Exposition
we learned so much from them magic just
seems shitty yeah you really gotta be
like in for the pain yeah the cost open
the bloody door John Jazz maybe this
isn't a good time
it's never a good time
he got red on you
people were very mad we didn't know his
accent uh apparently it's Welsh oh okay
the actor appreciate you guys looking
out in the past few years
I've been in a kind of dark place I
thought it was past it John
after all this time oh is that his kid
only decent thing I've been able to hold
on to was my little girl she's in a coma
doctors having a clue what cause that
are how secure it
but I spent enough time around you to
smell the stink of dark magic
I love if this is one of those episodes
of like a supernatural show where the
twist is it was just people he's still
in the Asylum yeah these bloody doctors
can't do anything maybe he can five
minutes not a second more
be like Insidious
like go into the astral plane
he's gonna get babadooked
I like how ponderous this one is it's
very like pensive yeah I'm John
mind if I have a look at your aura
do you do readings too make a good side
hustle hanging man let's have a look
inside
whoa cool whoa bloody hell
oh she cursed all right
Chaz Renee I'm gonna need a little more
than five minutes why what are you up to
John I'm calling in a specialist she
just barfed up a bunch of symbolism did
you just see the bees
want to have an MRI without the families
oh no
into the astral plane
collection
damn who you bringing in I was right in
the middle of a threesome with a dry out
and a cell both of whom I might add are
better in the back than you ever were
sure
it's not possession
because there's nothing here to possess
Seoul is gone well someone was there a
minute ago let's find out who has been
to the crossroads
[Music]
help me whoa Trish where are you in a
cage I think are you alone except when
he comes who the nasty man does he have
a name Pazuzu
I have many names
cool whoa if you want answers John
Constantine you'll have to come by for a
visit
when
oh that doesn't sound good nice
where are you going
Los Angeles apparently
city of demons
[Music]
gonna go for a Lucifer crossover yay we
are messing with deep dark magic here
just deeper than Newcastle
why did you say that name
the jump scares are great even if we can
save Trish you will
no pressure
I haven't seen you in 10 years do this
this is the union you want
there's always a price to pay no price
is too high when it comes to my little
girl
tell me that after you paid it mate
and animated movie taking the time to
show the luggage coming off is like I
like the pacing of this a lot because it
feels like a film
you think it's a trap
that's just La he was with John in
Newcastle it was years before Chaz
finally told me
tell me
I can't
it wasn't a request
whoa thought bubbles mind grapes
they were inseparable
John and Chaz I think it was the music
more than anything that bonded them had
to learn to play had to form a band Chaz
is Ringo
the Casanova Club was run by a twisted
named Alex Logue fancied himself a
sorcerer
called magical convocations in the rooms
under the club don't ask me what that
means I don't want to know
there's definitely some La [__] Chris
Angel's learning
to draw the dark magic down into the
physical world
I'm sorry
whoa when John found out what was
happening with the girl he decided Was
Gonna Save Astra oh and what better way
to stop a devil like Alex Lowe than by
summoning a bigger one
could beat up your devil
sweet
good use of like CGI animated blend yeah
oh
damn Savage
nice very nice
oh no wow
this is pretty pretty metal pretty
pretty intense he never wove a binding
spell around the demon which means he
couldn't control it the ghost is up
there play bass alone
sometimes you gotta play bass by
yourself
[Music]
oh
Elita gargoyle started real angry
damn
oh that's so messed up wow
[Music]
oh dude
that was that was a lot I need to
breather a little bit of trauma
oh about Newcastle I
I just
if you don't want to tell me you don't
have to
a whole clever making me question every
time someone's ever told me that now
they were they were a night nightmare
nurse
who came first night nurse or nightmare
nurse Marvel DC you won for anagrams
Chaz no endstrom
move the letters around monster monster
whoa
[Music]
I think we're expected enter freely end
of your own free will
I want to say that when I group my
guests into freely and of your own free
will
as
like a 70s Haunting movie
the old like satanic Panic air of horror
it's intense
whoa
whoa the pool's not ready yet
I've got to wait for the bodies to
liquefy and dredge Out the Bone
Sir Mr constant your reputation will
proceed
I like his slippers nice slippers what's
this all about I'll explain everything
at the party
what
what Jesus
Oh more Constantine movies please it is
just so intense oh yes what a band
not just a bassist oh oh yeah you got
this
damn dude
Jesus Christ they committed to the
rating and that's what I know the exact
moment the movie broke me
bats flying out somebody's ass is the
first never thought I'd see it that's a
secret portal to the Batcave
Batman Multiverse oh I love the live
action mixed
oh oh
[Music]
oh
scream intensifies oh
Jesus wow
two people in peril
ah
unpleasant see when they say these
things are rated all right I never
expect them to go quite as well wow
you don't like the 1920s something a bit
more contemporary perhaps Snyder cut
is this hell
my health
I've been visiting Los Angeles for years
everybody in this town sells their soul
for a Dream It's Harvey Weinstein doing
the work yeah buddy oh no people here
are so desperate so enamored of Illusion
oh yes not very happily Star-Lord
where's that at Warlock
[Music]
all the qualities we look for in
candidates for damnation
well a branch office of hell right here
like fast food but with the added
benefit of
Eternal damnation
that's what's in the pink chicken paste
but I've got competition
five other demons with similar
aspirations and I want that competition
eliminate
Monopoly the Kingpin of demons where is
she
safe
right here you could say she's a
prisoner of love
saying is true then any attack on him is
an attack on your daughter but we don't
know if it's true do we dissolve more
reason to not proceed oh he isn't dead
just displace
see the observatory yeah
not bad go visit Chaz later
on CHAS I'm coming what
[Music]
nice not not the best
is the whole town possessed it's a
radius around him yes it's like
something like hopping into different
people wherever Constantine goes that's
the first factual error there are no
signs that say 30 minute parking it'll
say 17 different things and you gotta
figure it out your own and get a ticket
this is La yeah I want My Little Girl
and if anyone can get it back it's you
tell that to astrolog
we follow Mr blobby's orders kill his
enemies and kiss his fat oh yeah
demon dogs
hounds of Hell
these are just the coyotes you just
don't hike graphic at night this is what
happens yeah he is driving a Prius this
is real footage of me on Mulholland
Drive one of Peru's competitors No Doubt
hey
are you a cummerbitch Constantine oh
show
come on
hope they got the coverage
[Music]
come on
whoa cool
Final Fantasy character damn dude
[Music]
oh
yeah
Uber driver professional five stars
really and I'm supposed to trust you
because because if you don't you're
gonna die now get in the car John
definitely in L.A and how do you know my
bloody name look maneuvering the vehicle
while controlling this body isn't easy
for me
dude you got Chaz let Chas Drive oh he
can't drive sideways the Mercedes up a
mountain
where the hell am I
Chas was here you still love him once
you've shared your life with someone
that love never leaves
no matter how much you might want it to
oh
I'm disappointed
gross
Baron hard Conan
how do I know that you really have a eh
oh I suppose I can give you a little
glimpse
oh
a little Freddy Krueger
[Music]
it's like an amalgamation of so many
different horror movies it's all so
gross and moist gooey
oh
[Music]
you need
whoa whoa get you out
[Music]
damn
oh
geez dude so viscous oh the look on your
face when I opened that portal and
tossed little Astra in
there was still so much innocence left
in here no
oh
whoa
I told you back in London that I had
many names
Nightmare Before Christmas suits off I'm
getting closer to finding them Jazz
demons like those five leave a psychic
residue like a slug leaves a trail of
slime no you don't have to come out
just bought that
in there
Guadalupe
even though bar is one of those Bell
things I know no I want to it's like
it's part of the Enterprise I gotta go
to Guadalupe's it's on me
it's an LA bar no smoking endorser
yeah
some things don't fly you got the Bell
you'd be grateful
laughs
Catherine Hahn
this would be the perfect place to cross
over man
dark magic nice to see you again John
all of them
the mayor
my body is
and blood
Stone and concrete tree
wowie my mind is thick with ten times 10
million memories
radiant with the histories of all my
people just bone in L.A
took La I am in you literally man
that's not in the tour
you're not going on the right door
that's true
I need your demons to fight these demons
we all use each other you know that
better than anyone people talk to John
Constantine the way they talk to John
Wick
chest so much Exposition sexiness and
constant use of the name that's why
Keanu Reeves plays them both John
I've been by 11 never like that
mclanta
ancient Aztec death God
[Applause]
iPhone 16.
Aztec empire died out New Gods Rose and
fell but mittalanta Cooley is a stubborn
and he just keeps hanging on New Gods
mcclendicularly God of Bones and of the
Grave mouth and of all that begins when
the heart stops
whoa thank you for letting me into your
house
[Music]
jeez you'd like smell this movie yeah I
know it's so dank and warm and icky yeah
putrid I am reduced to feeding on the
energy of the animals that die every day
and I am still a threat to Someone Like
You what prevents me from feeding on you
John Constantine
don't gobble me up until you've heard my
offer I am listening
I've got a phone call to make
classic
hitting all those classic heartbeats
it's like really interesting
a little Gothic in here boy careful this
shit's heavy Christ who knew there was a
black market in holy water
[Laughter]
yep have you delivered that guy to us oh
that that was a lie
[Music]
disease you five seek till you serve a
land that rightfully mine I will stop
you consume you body and soul
gentrification's a problem in Los
Angeles
build a high-rise here and I will
reclaim it
you gotta let the locals have their
spots oh
murk in the heads of the five families
getting stronger for it one of them runs
Disney and Warner Brothers I mean Harvey
Weinstein's running all of them he's got
to go back to prison
that's the spirit oh
[Music]
they were more worthy adversaries oh we
had an agreement and it's been fulfilled
not my fault if they took you down with
them please
this is so cool I know I really like
this I love this world
indeed John ugh
very well played trade by La well you
told me you wanted them all gone he
stays and runs his little franchise but
limits his activity to an acceptable
level
there's no acceptable level where that's
concerned damn
what out Trish
ugh
[Music]
oh he's gonna let him have it now I was
wrong before this is on You John
Constant saying this is all on you
oh as long as you work for me the girl
who's still alive in a coma what kind of
life is that yeah imprisoning some dank
ass demon heart
I urge you to consider letting Trisha's
body shut down naturally and to somehow
no
I can reduce your pain
make this decision easier for you
woof you think you can wave your magic
wand and make the world a better place
but all you ever do is make it worse it
does seem like a curse being involved
like as cool as all the magic is which
one yeah the cost is way more than the
another what another anything
you passed your limit time to go home
there's literally a bartender right
there
closer
[Music]
oh John incarcerated uh you're the last
person I expected to see get up off your
lazy ass and save my girl
where are you going visiting hours were
over at don't you worry about it love
I won't
magic magic
is fun for everyone
demon coma award I think so
foreign
you've cut me off from my supply chain
blocked my access to those slabs of
comatose meat
what do you want and let's make this
quick I've got a meeting with a producer
my life rights
England who comes to La La Land with a
head stuffed full of Dreams only to have
those dreams devoured by a Charming tap
dancing demon
[Music]
I mean it's a very compelling pitch I
mean very I could see it
a few doors between hell and Los Angeles
Johnny's opening the rest yeah
oh wow
so what's it gonna be in the game nerdy
oh you let the girl go
[Music]
here's Johnny Craig use yep yep yep
Little David Constantine the jackets I
want him I want them to be his official
sidekicks
make these plushies DC
I will have a little demon Constantine
eat about five competitors right well
how about 500. yeah
[Music]
geez can can one of those constantines
get in there and save his heart
damn you close it always embarrass in
front of Vanessa
we just got here
I'm going to do to sweat inner innocent
little Trish
but you said I lied the demon remember
what you said about sacrificing anything
for Trish yes then God help you
Renee get up what get up now
oh dude
no vechna
[Music]
the biggest weapon we had against you is
inside of you all along oh
come on
it's the cam Deva curse now gal that's
love you feel huh aren't you a creature
like you that's a cancer
damn I swear to you I'll give her back
[Music]
settle free
Johnny no attention John John
yeah
this is redemption enough
I have no unfinished business
the viscera the chunks so many chunks
foreign
[Music]
it was called The candeva Curse I had to
channel Renee and Trish's love for you
into and through Nagal
every last bit of it
it's gorgeous
oh what
Renee won't have any memory of you now
oh and Trish Trish has never known her
father oh no you miserable active [__]
the proper response is thank you Sean
what
oh
Renee and Trish no matter how much they
loved you it wasn't enough jazz
so I had to throw in some extra juice to
put the spell over the top
throw in US
oh oh dude the memory of those two kids
who grew up together in the pool
gone sorry
your name
oh John Constantine well it's a name I
hope I never hear again
oh I knew you could do it John
Morgan Freeman
which is worse that one being the one
who doesn't remember or being the one
who does it's all bad
damn that's sad you take good care of
him I will
um
not really a fan of old and wizard
thanks for the gesture though I'll see
you later if you like in her body that
might please you a little more we've
been there no thanks I'm getting home
sick
and if I'm Gonna Knock boots with the
city I'd rather it was London love
[Applause]
so trippy foreign
the drawings in the background are so la
like the they're behind the Hollywood
Highland Center from that view and then
this is like pieces that Rove the I
Heart Radio they're at Mel's Diner but
Kells Diner like so good show down Mateo
one of you actually made it out alive it
wasn't easy I'll tell you that oh never
there's me
so you're gonna take me back in right
now I could use a little company need my
mini me it's a little demon got stood
hanging out
hey
hey Insidious really was happening just
across
[Music]
okay that was intense yeah dude damn I
was exhausted in a good way yeah I was
like something else man that's a whole
other genre and experience and like yeah
that was Madness oh James dematteus so
he's a really good comic book writer uh
like an iconic comic book writer uh oh
Matt Ryan that's right yeah I love that
he just like wrote the hell out of this
very intimidating Laura Bailey no crazy
uh I don't know anybody else what an
incredible cast damn oh Kevin Michael
Richardson the old man
damn that was like I'm exhausted too
that was a journey that was one of the
most visceral like experiences I've had
in any animated film it was like
visceral and like heavy metal and and
yeah like strikingly for for these
movies I usually assume when I hear like
rated R it's gonna mean like okay
there's like they say the f word once
yeah it's like it'll feel more like a
PG-13 live action movie where there's
like a little bit of blood and like a
little bit of swear there's a butt but
yeah yeah exactly some side boob but
like this is like they just went that
was hard so intense and it wouldn't have
worked without that like if you don't
smell the frames if you don't feel all
that like just feel the demon energy
yeah it was so Gloppy
like did you uh do you ever see the
stranger things uh subtitles people were
making fun of those like
squelches and wetly this was real
squelchy oh yeah this is a swelling time
squelch intensifier man we got squelched
I'm so tired and it was so that so like
Constantine is a character I love
because it's so dark yeah and uh a lot
of my favorite runs are actually recent
like this guy Simon Spurrier writes the
hell out of him he writes them like uh
guy Richie dialogue but like with that
darkness and demonicness absolutely I
did not think that would translate
animated like just because of my pacing
I usually think of animated as like
gotta go fast yeah and this was like I
kept noticing how ponderous and like
wonderfully atmospheric it was but it
never got boring it was just so like
lived in yeah that's the thing about I
think you know in in the West in America
I think we're conditioned to look at
animation as cartoons for for short
attention spans first and foremost but
yeah like I I do appreciate that even
though these are aiming toward a wide
demographic certainly accomplishing the
youth like yeah it does have that
sensibility that does beg your attention
a little bit more and does you know
hearken to movies in a slightly
different way because it is medium
genre and I like that this is a great
example of Animation being a medium
because that was not a animated genre
film that was a animated dark R hardcore
sci-fi horror 70s like [__] satanic
Panic experience 100 man that was
intense so I I think Not only was it
like an incredibly atmospheric
experience but it also really puts you
in the world of Constantine to the point
where I want like more justice league
dark worlds in this animated I really
want to see Constantine in movies like
properly no I mean you know I I still
have not seen the Keanu version
it's not the comic but it's great yeah
yeah and there's the series too which
which uh Matt Ryan does the voice yeah
or does the the before he also he is
Constantine in the series and uh and
that was what CW or whatever yeah which
is interesting to see berlante on this
animated film because I think it's the
first berlante film and berlantis all
the live action stuff yeah so I'm
wondering how that crossover happened
did no yeah I was wondering if this is
like wish fulfillment done on that
aspect because I know that as much as
people love that show yeah you can't go
as hard as they went here obviously and
yeah like I love I don't know like
obviously horror stuff very much appeals
to me but I love diving into this side
of the world just because like you said
it is so atmospheric and there is so
much like there's a different Dynamic
than a lot of the other you know
superheroes of varying stripes are
Supernatural to some extent you know
there's a lot of that quality but when
you're dealing with demons and spirits
and magic and Voodoo uh yeah there's
just like a darkness of core and like an
elemental quality that I think they ring
really nicely here out of the
proceedings and I'm so glad no one else
was in it I was like you know sometimes
they do that like opening scene ties
into the universe thing this was just
Constantine it did yeah we had Batman
last time like other people which was
fun
like I liked the the tie-in team up
element but this was great because it
just got to play in his War world yeah
it would have been distracting like I I
talk about the Batman all the time as
I'm so glad Pattinson's his own thing
this was nice to be its own thing I
didn't have to think about you know
tie-ins and things the only Easter eggs
I was focused on was the LA stuff yeah
right the Caruso symbol like did you
notice the uh so the Grove angelenos uh
The Grove and uh the Americana are owned
by that billionaire [__] that tried
to run for mayor uh and the symbol of
those two little things was in the
background while they were eating at
Kells uh but it was like slightly
changed I was like little things like
that that are only for La people yeah
yeah yeah and I love yeah it's like I I
I I I feel like so much so much of
superhero-ish stuff or or comic book
Cinema takes place in New York yeah and
I know the West Coast Avengers style I
know that there are yeah like like other
Regional characters and stuff but I am
always City of Angels the city of demons
was great I like that La was a character
in this and actor that whole thing thing
was wild to me and I love and that's the
kind of thing that I think is especially
fun and cool in this pocket of this
universe is yeah you do have stuff where
it is like completely weird and and
demented and kind of abstracted like
that that feels like some kind of weird
Neil Gaiman thing yeah like the
personification of a city and like it
was beautiful Exposition because it was
like compassion like there was
connection it was really interesting it
was a really good and like I'm somebody
you know having grown up here and having
talked to so many people who have moved
here like I'm I'm sort of enamored with
and fascinated by the spirit of this
particular City because
it's just the kind of place that is
everything that is said about it it is
so many things and so many experiences
that you have to be here and you have to
be here for a while to really know it
and even then you never know it because
everyone's got their own experience of
it but having just left for two weeks or
a week and a half and come back
it's a really hard place to like
quantify and it's so interesting to see
it be a character yeah and and and then
in this story that has yeah you've got
this Angelic presence of the city but
you also have just tons and tons of
demons who could easily stand in for
various treacherous figures in in actual
reality and different like that's the
other thing too is this is one of those
ones where I'm like this isn't like
beating me around the head and neck with
some kind of allegorical concept however
it's really easy to like transplant the
map of things happening onto real
dynamics that take place every day
trauma of La like they lean into like
the demon being like yeah of course he's
gonna Nest up here like of course you're
gonna find people that are just giving
everything away and it's really a
beautiful story at the end with uh the
sacrifice like I really like that John
Constantine gets nothing he even had to
sacrifice like an old friendship
Constantine himself there's a cost and
that was painful and beautiful no
totally and I like that both of these
movies have had elements of his past or
people who he knows you know and this
one going even further yeah now that you
don't have now you don't need them
necessarily to like help flesh him out
as a character I feel like in the first
uh uh in uh what was that justice league
dark you know it's like you're kind of
meeting other people involved with him
and they sort of flesh out who he is but
yeah here it's it's nice to just have it
within the family or within you know
just his life and then yeah like really
appropriate I I was I was
I like the double twist because it kind
of lets you off in a in a in a still as
tragic magic kind of way where it's like
Chaz goes off and he's none the wiser of
John he's the advisor of uh of um his
family his wife and daughter and then
they are none the wiser of him and at
first I thought it was going to be that
like only the two of them were gonna be
aware and they were gonna be free and
that's that's the most heartbreaking but
this is yeah like even sort of sadder
it's just like John's alone with this
also like how many people with mental
health issues and drugs and addictions
have that life in La like I thought it
was really beautiful yeah it was like
where people put all our love into you
but like you don't give anything back
sometimes yeah and it changes you and
sometimes that love doesn't remain the
same yeah even if you're not physically
you know inserting and using that energy
you know literally and the people like
La her his self going and comforting the
new Angelino who's lost in wonder in the
streets is very very symbolic and very
you know direct I I what a beautiful
movie that was so harrowing man and that
whole montage about like I am everything
that has happened here like yeah that
was stunning yeah it's like it was well
attenuated because also too like seeing
all the Newcastle stuff like I like that
yeah you have your londony elements your
your UK elements and those are vivid and
then you come over here and and you know
there is a different vibe a different
pulse a different energy and then yeah
you've got little bits of like astral
plane like the stuff where they're
cutting back and forth with what's the
nurse uh the nightmare nurse yeah which
is which is an interesting take I also I
had an interesting thing where I I liked
that he sacrificed his Redemption but
also he was willing to sacrifice one
life for the greater good because that's
something that's like you don't usually
deal with that with Heroes like it's
always like we got to save every life
and like you know even one life matters
but like he had to do the trolley
problem
that girl's still in hell but he saved
everyone yeah and like what a oh yeah
and tying that Newcastle and having that
flashback having those jump scares
making the jump scares actually
legitimate not just jump scares yeah
like this was a palm sweaty experience
totally totally knees week I could go
for some spaghetti but not red sauce
because I'm thinking about viscous
membranes yeah you'll do an exorcist in
vomiting man that was so and that's the
other thing there's just so many so many
wet gooey horror movie vibes from yeah
there's like a little bit Evil Dead too
a little bit of Exorcist a little bit
like old gothic stuff yeah a little bit
of like heavy metal Gore Grindhouse [__]
thrown in lots of genre bending and all
of it serving the story now that it felt
extra none of it felt like it was of the
world right yeah it's like you're like
where you're in a demon world of course
you're gonna have like a a pool made of
liquefied body
and it's and it's that too it's so
absurd James Gunn yeah you hire Robert
daggers and you make a Constantine movie
oh you make it moist fun you make it
viscous and you make it like the North
End meets the lighthouse dude fun
James Gunn makes Superman James Gunners
reaction makes Constantine James Gunn
sticks around for the room oh he's
watching right now he's watching right
now and mangled next Swamp Thing you get
your math Yvonne Authority sure you get
your uh mushietti Batman yeah that's a
universe yeah
James Gunn you heard it I'm available to
consult with at any time
since you're watching we appreciate you
uh I love this I didn't mean to dropped
it just came to me it was it was a
torrent totally it's all good and just
all the all the lying and promising and
backstabbing and and and yeah the
peripheral magic it's just yeah this is
like nicely nicely like otherworldly and
also nicely grounded yeah it was it was
I'm glad I I kind of thought the sequel
if this is a sequel to what we met
Constantine through would be about the
house and I kind of like that instead it
was like everything yeah yeah that he
calls up like all the other possible
demons so cool to be like hey I'm
stepping back on your territory and you
had the Aztec guy like there's so many
things that happen and it's a dense hour
and a half but it's also paced really
ponderously and I'm glad it didn't
become like third act action like it
didn't do the the superhero problem it
didn't become like a punch him yeah it
stayed really really dense man I love
that that's gonna that's gonna be hard
to put in the list yeah when we rank
these we're gonna have a top-notcher
we're gonna have a Time ranking these uh
well we could go on for an hour and a
half because it was a dense hour and a
half but that was a hell of an
experience I hope this one did well I
hope people enjoyed it I loved this one
Constantine city of demons thank you
let's give a patron of the day shot
hopefully they're not you know someone
that doesn't like blood and gorks
they'll never have seen this one they
won't know we shouted them out but let
us give some love I feel like there's
some go-to's that I always give love I'm
gonna go with a different one because I
don't want to seem like I pick favorites
uh no that I I do but I'm not gonna hear
oh because that's that's the demon way
I'm gonna go with a really cool name it
is Chris yes uh Chris it's a good one
for this but it feels right right like I
feel like wamhoff is a name that either
is a Demon Hunter or someone that writes
about demons like I feel like wamhoff is
a book I'd go into a library and I'd
read down the spine I'd be like all
righty transcribe the literature and
translated into 17 archaic languages
without the Wim Hof volume 13. we would
not be able to do it yes yes we would
not be able to summon the demons
it's also kind of close to a Wim Hof
like the Wim Hof method of breathing
totally which is maybe why I think it's
effective Yeah Yeah Chris seems like a
well-read oh yeah yeah
is he does the Lord's work out there so
I hope he also follows Wim Hoff and does
definitely does some good breathing you
can verify that all right get on the Wim
Hof method get on the the ancient
scriptures and save us from the demons
frankly we need you Chris Wim Hof
we appreciate you that is gonna do it uh
thank you all so much for watching this
with us that was an experience man this
was so so very good uh let us know in
the comments what you thought of city of
demons if you're from LA and you saw any
Easter eggs let me know if I'm this
Danny I want to know because that was
really fun for me let me know in the
comments what you want us to watch next
and where would you put this now now
that we're 17 in where would this rank
on yours we're gonna keep going we're
gonna find out what's next when we talk
to Greg but until then same bad time
same bad Channel we're back at it we'll
see you soon much love by reject Nation
go with God
and Wim Hof
[Music]